welcome to this video playing Silvo with
Wyatt we don't know anything about him
no Fleck nothing okay defend it with a
quick knight c6 chigorin style that's an
unconventional moving away Bishop f5
year they normally play with Bishop to
g4 her place afore he is the night
before coming and I have the check right
so not oops what's this I interesting
just now decided to take that okay I'd
say that's that playable I mean it it's
probably not great but certainly a play
will move his bishop is now is now gone
maybe I'm not sure that all this it
could also play c5 to obstruct his
Bishop this would actually have this is
maybe an idea the rukon be one can also
support a further before so this might
make some sense in connection with the
rook being on b1 and he cannot play
Bishop d6 quickly to exchange my F for
Bishop you know okay let's see how is
going to develop now maybe with 97 to g6
or something like that well it looks
like
but okay maybe I can play this
pre-emptive move so that an ID g6 Bishop
g3 a threat in age 5 it's an aggressive
IDM not sure how good it is but
interesting and also it makes sure that
yeah yeah I can play age 5 and ask him
how it's going to set up his pieces now
ok it's just returning but this this
obviously took took quite some time so
just Bishop e7 and is got very little
space ok let's play this supporting move
it's not clear if I should ever castle I
mean I have a very nice space advantage
in any case and I don't really see much
counter play happening maybe 97-95 yeah
this this could be a serious counter
play yeah should I just push further
here with a 45 maybe it also increases
the control over the e5 square yeah ok
I want to exchange this bishop really I
wanted to play Quincy one ok I can also
go here where I definitely must exchange
the night only 492 coming that's an
interesting it probably wants to gain
the d6 square maybe 95 was also
interesting looking at the c6 square
what about ok I'm as usual behind on the
clock need to be at least somewhat quick
may I didn't play that well not at all
yeah the night on before this a very
peculiar piece it's not doing that much
but it controlled c6 which is quite
valuable now the night is not attacking
anything but it controls the importance
in six square ok but I'm quick on the
sea phone ok he's got he's got after
Luke see a juke see one takes cannot
take where I can take with the Queen
because i have quincy seven min the
tempo okay he might want to to see once
you go to h4 maybe maybe
okay maybe I can play like that
Rukia should be possible look at you I
can take c8 and on Queen hof Quincy one
this was my DM
okay he's not trying to go to h4 anymore
so I can go back if it takes I'm taking
with the Queen to answer night a 2 with
Quincy 70 it's allowing this that's a
somewhat surprising okay and I'm
switching back here if I go to g1 I also
have some ideas in connection with the
book on the seventh time morning it's
going to play wiki seven here
I that was a bad move he can play wookie
seven yeah this is not the problem in
training this is not in terms of keeping
everything together
yeah he's probably hoping to do
something in regards to my time check
the position is absolutely not something
that you can can play for when oops are
what was this I wasn't on c1 I made this
mouse slip again is this assist
disbeliever white resides where was it
was on c3 I just wanted to I was
surprised that he played and I wanted to
put it back and play played this city
stuff yeah it's a it's a it's about
equal this position I think I can I can
just drop back here you can always play
this the sort of perpetual thing with
the night I have no way out there this
was really a badly played by me out of
the opening because right here White's
position is totally overwhelming what
did i do here yeah well the computer
wants to play something totally
different Queen a form Queen a form in
95 that's very direct now maybe even I
mean it's quite clear that black is in
bad shape but I didn't this is probably
not great I am I shouldn't play for here
this was just a bit this was to this was
too hasty thrombley not spoiling it very
much but I have all the time here to to
further improve with this huge edge and
space and the two bishops I'm very am
clearly favored him a computer wants to
take on a five
which I didn't consider really didn't
want to spoil the points pawn structure
but there is some point if you look at
this for example I mean this is just a
wrong position I have pressure on the B
file now I have it Sam it's something to
consider and here he is definitely out
of the woods definitely c6 is also not
leading to much it's a bit of a bit of a
strange case this is night on this night
on before is some yeah it's not doing
much but it's also a nuisance it's
probably very dry why should the whole
thing he has always this kind of this
kind of attacks on the rook and it's
very difficult to make any any headway
we we shuffled the bid and he allowed a
bit of an invasion on the sea far but
there was nothing nothing really
happening and I made this this mouse
slip in a way blundering the rook yeah I
should I can just play whatever I mean
also taking Andrew here this is probably
if anything somewhat better for wide but
nothing nothing special really okay
thanks for watching